this morning we continue our kindness
101 series with Steve Hartman sharing
stories built around kindness and
character and the people who have
mastered those qualities today's lesson
is creativity Steve and his kids show us
how one man's quest to carve the
greatest and most elaborate pumpkin of
all allowed him to unleash his own
creative Spirits good morning this is
Meryl my daughter and today's lesson is
creativity very creative sign today
thank you for a definition we go over to
your brother Emmett below the dictionary
desk Abbott good morning so creativity
is essentially taking an old thing and
looking at it in a new way that's kind
of cool it's kind of like thing
I think in this case under the desk
right turning convention on its head
literally on its head and Emmett's case
exactly creativity makes things funnier
easier or more beautiful than they would
have been otherwise and of course I have
a story to illustrate this is about a
man who's carved out quite a niche for
himself in the art World a man so
creative it's scary
when you watch the villafane family of
Michigan dig into their Halloween
pumpkins go start carving the first
question that comes to mind is there he
goes there he goes what a pumpkin ever
do to them Norman Bates carved more
kindly and yeah this is how Ray
villafane teaches his kids how to start
on a pumpkin oh and not just his kids I
think this tool
he goes around the schools and tries to
get other kids to adopt the same skin
him alive approach if you want to make a
good pumpkin you have to push the limits
there's clearly a Madness to his mouth
but Rey is not completely out of his
gourd in fact okay he may be a genius
it's a different way of thinking for the
past 15 years Rey has spent every
October in his basement Studio
Reinventing the art of pumpkin carving
using sculpting tools instead of knives
Rey can now take a pumpkin and over the
course of about eight hours turn it into
a truly Museum quality fruit
to me you carve a pumpkin to transform
it into something that's alive
believe it or not all these started out
as single pumpkins each carving more
improbable than the next each creation
challenging the limits of what is
pumpkinly possible I'm so obsessive when
I get into something and I'll go to
sleep I stay up all night I keep doing
it has he been like this since you met
him
um pretty much there's an apple honey
Rey's Wife Tammy says pumpkins were just
the beginning I need a knife they merely
opened his eyes to an infinitely
carvable world today the former grade
school teacher Scopes full-time he makes
models like this for toy companies and
he's starting to get into sand sculpting
too this is what he made the first time
he ever tried
Ray clearly has a gift such a gift it's
almost a curse I see the eyes are too
big like so many people who are the best
at what they do structure of the face is
not right Rey is rarely satisfied with
anything he does would you throw it away
I've thrown away better ones than this
yeah and although it drives his wife
nuts Ray says it's a healthy Neurosis
that fuels his creativity done and of
course 15 years of practice doesn't hurt
either
Rey revolutionized the jack-o-lantern
and before you say you could never do
that you're not a creative person let's
hear what Ray has to say on the subject
good morning Ray good morning do you
worry about making mistakes when you're
trying something new usually never
set
when I got people watching me sometimes
when people are watching if you want to
stay safe so we don't explore which
means that we don't create is this why
so many creative things happen in
people's basements yeah probably it's
right so do you have any specific tips
for tapping into your creative side yes
losing expectations because sometimes
when we want to we want to create
something we make the goal more
important than the process
what do you do when you're not feeling
particularly creative
go for walks go for runs if you're
stressed you can never be creative I've
noticed absolutely you're
so that has water in it those water all
your thoughts talking and you want an
idea but there's no room in it because
there's so much talking you got to pour
all that out and go like this and all of
a sudden
ideas and creativity just pour right in
all right well you've given us so much
to work with thank you for all the great
advice oh thank you bye bye you know
maybe we should invent a new way to
carve pumpkins like maybe with your
teeth no yeah with your teeth why not
with your teeth oh
what if you don't caramel at all
okay happy Halloween everyone we'll work
on that we'll see you next time until
then stay kind
Marilyn Emmett always seem like they're
having a great time no matter what
they're talking about I'll bet you guys
are good pumpkin Carvers I can't like
the smell or feel a pumpkins Katie
doesn't I don't like the car smell or in
fact you were going to post a photo we
got no photos just Katie doing the
pumpkins there's not I'm not in a single
shot I'm standing 10 feet away well I
was never very good no not a little bit
I like to bake the pumpkin seeds though
put a little salt on it yeah